[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée dans les Yvelines
avec au programme de l'actualité des
infos pratiques et des idées de sortie
voici le sommaire de ce 22 novembre
le début de la 38e campagne hivernale
des Restos du cœur une ouverture dans un
contexte de fortination conséquences les
24 centres dans le département
s'apprêtent à accueillir davantage de
personnes l'association doit faire face
également à beaucoup d'inconnus en en
parle avec Fabienne Lambert responsable
des Restos du cœur dans les Yvelines
ce pain au chocolat yvelinoa n'est pas
comme les autres il y a quelques
semaines la viennoiserie a été
distinguée comme la meilleure de France
un prix remporté par Didier le 2 mai
dans la boule en don la boulangerie est
installée à Poissy nous l'avons en suivi
en pleine préparation de ses pains au
chocolat et puis découverte également
d'une exposition jusqu'au 13 février
Louis XV passion d'un roi est visible au
château de Versailles à un hommage au
souverain à l'occasion du tri centenaire
de son sacre 400 œuvres pour découvrir
sa fonction de monarque en savoir plus
sur ses passions sa vie de famille et
son affluence sur les arts de son temps
et ce sera tout à l'heure dans le 7 8 à
suivre dans la page culture avec au menu
aussi des invités pour venir parler
d'événements à venir sur le territoire
yvelinois et notamment la cinquième
édition de solidence la soirée
caritative au profit du Téléthon revient
ce sera ce samedi à la Ferme du Manet à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et pour en parler
en plateau soit el tir animateur de la
soirée également Daniel de salle de
l'air qui est pilote du collectif
solidense bonsoir à vous deux bonsoir et
vous êtes également Daniel de salle de
l'air le président de l'association
ce qui est à l'origine qui co-organise
cette soirée en deux mots le concept de
la soirée solidence quel est-il
peut-être pas collectif d'une vingtaine
d'associations qui se mettent ensemble
pour créer un événement autour du
Téléthon et qui permet aussi d'avoir
toute une soirée d'ambiance autour de la
danse autour de la danse et on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler tout à l'heure
je lui disais à l'origine il y a
l'association ski danse si vous pouvez
dire deux mots de présentation sur ce
qui danse une association
c'est une association très ancienne
puisqu'elle va la plus de 40 ans
actuellement elle est né en
1980 sur 50 ans en Yvelines et elle est
toujours là avec 300 plus 330 adhérents
aujourd'hui donc elle se porte bien
voilà Skydance Skydance qui c'est
Skydance c'est marqué à l'anglais si on
préfère le prononcer à l'anglaise parce
que Sky comme ça ça fait penser au ciel
aussi donc on parlera de Skydance on
parlera tout à l'heure bien sûr de cette
soirée solidence qui est au programme le
week-end prochain dans les Yvelines du
cinquième édition également pour un
autre événement et je me tourne vers mon
autre invité c'est Bernard Delattre
bonsoir bonsoir c'est le 5e Salon du
Livre des lancers qui se déroulera à la
Commanderie s'organiser par les Amis du
passé avec bien sûr de la ville de
longcourt et l'Agglo de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et pour
présenter très brièvement aussi cet
événement sa particularité c'est
peut-être aussi le lieu où il est
organisé cette commanderie qui est une
bâtisse du du 12e siècle
et là chaque année on a un thème
différent cette année c'est quand le
film rencontre le livre et on a
président de donneur Evelyne dress qui
est actrice elle a été réalisatrice et
maintenant les romancières donc le
samedi soir elle va animer deux films
elle a tendresse bordel à partir de
18h30 ou avec Bernard Giraudeau et
ensuite le film pas d'amour sans amour
qu'elle a réalisé elle va parler tout ça
et le dimanche nous aurons à la
Commanderie nous aurons le toute la
journée Nelson Monfort qui a fait aussi
du cinéma sportif il a joué son rôle et
on va pas forcément tout dévoiler parce
qu'on va en parler dans un sens mais en
tout cas on a compris la thématique
littérature et cinéma il y a forcément
des passerelles entre les deux mondes on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler tout à
l'heure Bernard
et bien sûr aussi les autres
universalité qui seront qui ne seront
pas oublié devant en parler tout à
l'heure également les journalistes de la
rédaction de tv70 pour le moment il y a
Céline chat qui est avec nous en plateau
bonsoir avec vous à suivre les
informations du jour de quoi parle-t-on
dans l'actualité aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'informations aujourd'hui entre autres
bien sûr le lancement de la 38e campagne
d'hivernale des Restos du cœur la suite
du conflit sur le projet prison à
Magnanville et on parlera aussi culture
et sport à suivre également l'astuce du
chef que vous retrouvez à présent tous
les mardis dans le 7 8 et livinoise
Virginie Legrand vous donne une idée
pour un apéritif à base de saumon ce
sera également tout à l'heure mais tout
de suite coup d'oeil à la météo de
demain
et ce mercredi les conditions seront peu
ouprou les mêmes qu'aujourd'hui dans les
Yvelines de la pluie est attendue dans
l'ensemble du territoire comptait 8
degrés le matin à Rambouillet Versailles
et Houdan ce sera 9 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie elle l'après-midi des
gouttes toujours avec peut-être un ciel
plus clair il fera 11 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et Houdan 10
degrés à Rambouillet ce mercredi 23
novembre c'est la Saint Clément
[Musique]
les informations du jour avec Céline
Charles et on commence avec le chiffre
du jour c'est 16000 oui 16000 c'est le
nombre de personnes accueillies par les
Restos du Coeur dans les Yvelines la 38e
campagne hivernale de l'association
commence aujourd'hui sa principale
action reste l'aide alimentaire
disponible dans plusieurs points de
distribution du territoire la demande va
encore probablement augmenter cette
année en raison de la hausse des prix
d'ailleurs l'association prend désormais
en compte les frais d'énergie de
chauffage en plus des revenus et du
loyer pour savoir si une personne peut
bénéficier de l'aide on abordera tous
ces sujets avec notre invité dans un
instant adouci aussi qui fait réagir
depuis quelques mois sur le territoire
Yves Linois l'état maintient le projet
de prison à Magnanville exactement c'est
une information du maire de Magnanville
Michel Lebouc vendredi soir les contre
propositions des opposants ont été
rejetés les sites alternatifs que
proposaient certains un certain
habitants et élus n'ont pas été acceptés
par l'État et l'agence publique pour
l'immobilier et la justice élu et
habitants justement protester contre les
deux lieux envisagés jusqu'à lors le
premier à 100 mètres des habitations et
le second à 150 mètres du lycée Léopold
Sédar Senghor la préfecture assez
pendant accepté deux poursuivre les
discussions sur des sites alternatifs
une nouvelle rencontre de vrais être
tenue prochainement le sport et l'équipe
de France de football qui fait ses
débuts ce soir à la Coupe du Monde et
oui Grégory on l'attend tous c'est ce
soir à 20h que la France fera son entrée
dans la Coupe du Monde au Qatar et la
Frontera l'Australie pour son premier
match quelques communes des Yvelines
vont diffuser la rencontre sur grand
écran vous le voyez sur l'infographie
qui s'affiche la salle des fêtes de la
mare aux loups opéré en Yvelines la
Fabrique à Bois d'Arcy l'espace Robert
Thierry à Noisy-le-Roi et le Cosec 4e
sur scène une diffusion une diffusion
vous le savez qui fait débat depuis
plusieurs semaines mais qu'en pense les
Yvelinois Julien Leroy et Régine ralech
sont allés recueillir leurs avis alors
oui je vais la suivre même si j'avoue
que du fait de des choix de housse se
déroule
la coupe cette année j'ai un peu du mal
surtout au niveau environnemental
un truc qui s'est passé à 12 ans le
choix a été fait je sais pas maintenant
qu'on va
on va chercher les problèmes les gens
ils veulent bien regarder le les matchs
de foot donc quand nous laisse
tranquille quoi avec cette histoire
pourquoi me suivre vous ne voulez pas
suivre cette coupe du monde de football
cette année parce que de toute façon
c'est d'abord à l'étranger moi j'ai bien
quand c'était en France parce que là je
l'ai suivi de près et qu'en plus les
chaînes privées
ont tout ramassé au point de vue contrat
mais Coupe du monde je trouve que c'est
plus intéressant et une ambiance
particulière après il va les Français
ont gagné la fois précédente donc
j'espère que ils vont poursuivre dans
cette lancée l'ambiance en plus c'est au
Qatar c'est beau c'est magnifique du
coup à ce moment on va bien se divertir
nous la France Australie coup d'envoi ce
soir à 20h et c'est un mondial ou
l'Île-de-France est très bien représenté
28 joueurs présents au 14 dans les
différentes sélections étaient formées
dans des clubs de la région et même 8
passer par les rangs du Paris
Saint-Germain le camp des Loges bien sûr
basé à Saint-Germain-en-Laye on reste
dans le sport Céline avec notre image du
jour oui comment faire en sorte que le
handisport contribue au changement de
regard entre mon Dieu handicap et monde
valide c'était la question posée à 80
jeunes de 13 à 25 ans ce matin par la
Fondation Banque Populaire val-de-france
et les idées à terre les jeunes avaient
la journée pour travailler en groupe et
trouver des solutions à cette
problématique avant de passer devant un
jury un événement appelé idée qui vise à
sensibiliser sur le monde de
l'entrepreneuriat le badiste
paralympique merylocate était présent
sur place pour aider les élèves écoutez
les propos recueillis par notre
journaliste Patrick Jacques de dissimus
sur les objectifs de cette journée notre
objectif c'est d'utiliser en fait
l'entrepreneuriat pour permettre aux
jeunes de s'autonomiser de monter des
projets d'avoir des compétences sociales
numériques psychosociales apprendre le
leadership le travail en équipe et donc
ils montent un projet vraiment de A à Z
comme un entrepreneur disait une autre
image du sport forcément puisque là on
est sur la thématique handisport ça leur
donne une autre image peut-être aussi de
la banque ça leur donne envie surtout
envie d'aller plus loin avoir l'esprit
de cohésion et entrepreneuriale
justement puisque c'est l'objectif de
cette journée de produire enfin de
sortir présenter un beau projet voilà
entrepreneur je viens parce que parce
que je sais qu'il y aura un échange qui
va être hyper hyper sympa ça va être
interactif ils vont être là on va
pouvoir discuter donc moi j'adore
j'adore pouvoir parler de ce que mon
parcours de leur motiver un peu parce
qu'il y en a qui font pas beaucoup de
sport peut-être leur dire bon attends je
suis valide et je fais même pas de sport
il a pas de main il en fait il est trop
il est meilleur que moi donc peut-être
que je me bouge histoire de les motiver
un petit peu aussi une opération inédite
à présent du 25 novembre 2 décembre si
vous êtes détenteur d'armes trouvez ou
bien hérité qu'elle soit déclarée ou non
vous pouvez vous rendre dans des sites
spécialement ouverts pour l'occasion
dans les Yvelines c'est soit au
commissariat de Fontenay-le-Fleury soit
la brigade de gendarmerie de Rambouillet
deux choix s'offriront à vous ensuite
vous dessaisir de ces armes ou bien les
enregistrer c'est une démarche simple et
gratuite et vous n'encourez aucune
poursuite judiciaire ou administrative
si vous venez avec une arme sans
autorisation pour terminer ces
informations du jour direction le
château de Versailles alors exactement à
partir d'aujourd'hui mardi 22 novembre
vous pouvez vous rendre dans le salon de
l'abondance au château de Versailles
pour observer le somptio bureau de Louis
XIV restaurer il est passé par un long
travail de recherche et de restauration
mené au sein du Centre de recherche et
de restauration des musées de France
classés trésor national et à qui en 2015
c'est une des rares un des rares
exemples de mobiliers de cette époque
encore conservée merci Céline et si vous
aussi près de chez vous êtes témoin d'un
fait d'une information qui vous fait
réagir n'hésitez pas le partager à nous
le dire sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news dans la
Une de cette actualité à la Une de cette
actualité on en a parlé c'est la le
lancement de la 38e campagne des Restos
du Coeur pour en parler une invité nous
a rejoint en plateau ses Fabienne
Lambert bonsoir responsable
départemental des Restos du Coeur dans
les Yvelines on le disait une campagne
qui est lancée dans un contexte de forte
inflation vous l'abordez comment du coup
cette nouvelle campagne cette campagne
alors on l'aborde sereinement parce
qu'il faut être serein mais on s'attend
en fait on se prépare à accueillir de
nombreuses personnes puisqu'en fait
depuis le mois d'avril on a cueilli 15%
de personnes supplémentaires et depuis
un an c'est plus 25 % de personnes qu'on
accueille le chiffre était donné tout à
l'heure 16000 personnes accueillies
c'est un chiffre qui est largement
dernier je vous aurais dit 12000 c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui précarité inflation
il y a forcément un lien ça exactement
cette précarité alors cette année a été
très particulière puisque nous
accueillons des Ukrainiens aussi donc on
accueille à peu près 10% de famille
ukrainiennes dans
l'Ukraine en février on a à peu près 10%
des familles de parmi les personnes
accueillies 10% ce sont des familles
ukrainiennes et puis après à partir du
mois d'avril on a vu quand même on a vu
tout de suite arriver cette ce problème
autour de toute la crise qui existe avec
des familles qui ont de plus en plus des
soucis pour boucler leur et qui sont
dans des arbitrages entre ce que je me
chauffe maintenant est-ce que je mange
et tout et donc on voit de plus en plus
de familles aussi assez nombreuses qui
ont du mal à boucler leur boutique qui
viennent frapper à la porte des Restos
du cœur et ça va aggraver davantage vous
pensez la situation elle risque de
s'aggraver dans les dans les prochains
mois avec eux encore plus de personnes
effectivement ce qui fait que
aujourd'hui on se trouve dans une
situation délicate puisque on accueille
plus de personnes je vous cacherai pas
que la nourriture coûte de plus en plus
cher vous le constatez tous donc à la
fois on a des problèmes on se dit qu'on
va risque d'avoir des problèmes de
ressources donc tous les dons seront les
bienvenus et puis on souhaiterait bien
accueillir aussi de nouveaux bénévoles
pour nous aider en fait à accueillir au
mieux toutes ces personnes en fait parce
que l'inflation oui forcément un impact
sur ces personnes accueillies avec cette
précarité qui augmente c'est un impact
aussi sur le fonctionnement de
l'association au jour le jour
moi l'association je vois simplement la
facture des camions qui livrent qui
livre aujourd'hui tous les centres et
ben la hausse elle suit ce que vous
pouvez observer sur le prix de l'essence
du diesel voilà d'où la nécessité vous
vous le disiez alors les bénévoles on va
en parler mais de toujours donner il
faut être aussi donné on en a peut-être
encore plus besoin que les autres années
tout à fait sur le profil des personnes
accueillies est-ce que vous voyez de
nouvelles personnes venir au Resto du
Coeur aujourd'hui alors dans les
personnes en fait alors nous avons des
Ukrainiens alors on a aussi du coup on a
un certain nombre de maman avec des
enfants et tout qui sont venus toutes
seules nous accueillons toujours
toujours toujours beaucoup de maman
isolées avec des enfants c'est toujours
la grande majorité des personnes que
nous accueillons en fait au resto du
coeur et maintenant comment savoir de
plus en plus de grandes familles les
familles qui ont du mal à boucler les
budgets moi j'ai regardé avant de venir
les derniers chiffres pour vous donner
une idée on a quand même 45% à peu près
des personnes accueillies qui sont
mineures on sait aussi il y a un public
fragile qui est alors vous parliez des
mineurs il y a aussi la précarité
étudiante on en parle de plus en plus
aujourd'hui il y a ce chiffre qui a été
donné cette enveloppe débloquée par par
l'état de 10 millions d'euros pour les
associations justement qui assurent la
distribution alimentaire et c'est sur le
sujet de la précarité étudiante est-ce
que vous pensez que ça va dans le bon
sens et ce qu'il en faudrait davantage à
votre avis moi je vous dis il en faut
toujours davantage si vous me posez la
question c'est toujours bon à prendre
mais si on peut en avoir plus tant mieux
oui les étudiants sont dans une
situation compliquée et d'ailleurs on
parle de la crise énergétique mais nous
on sort aussi de la crise covid comme
tout le monde et nous avions été amenés
pendant la crise covid d'ailleurs à
faire des livraisons auprès de résidence
étudiantes notamment à
Vélizy-Villacoublay et justement la
crise covid on en a parlé avec beaucoup
d'associations il y a eu forcément aussi
un impact sur le nombre de bénévoles
aujourd'hui vous vous lisez aussi tout à
l'heure il y a un grand besoin de
bénévoles
en fait nous sommes quand même plus de
1000 mais en fait en face de 16000
personnes accueillies ça n'a rien
d'étonnant on cherche des bénévoles oui
parce que nous ce qui est le plus connu
en fait c'est c'est tout ce qu'on fait
en domaine de l'aide alimentaire mais en
fait ce que vivent les Restos du coeur
c'est à sortir les personnes de la
précarité moi ce que je souhaite aux
personnes quand je les accueille c'est
trouver une solution pour ne plus les
voir demain au resto du coeur qui n'est
plus besoin de nous et donc ce que les
gens voient moins c'est qu'on cherche
aussi des bénévoles pour faire du
soutien à la recherche d'emploi pour
faire de l'aide à la justice tout un tas
d'activités donc les gens qui ont envie
de faire ça peuvent venir nous voir nous
serons enchantés et puis on cherche
aussi des personnes sur des métiers soit
plus administratifs on cherche des
chauffeurs vous voyez c'est très très
vaste donc si vous avez envie si vous
avez des compétences n'hésitez pas même
sans compétences on vous trouverez
quelque chose à faire donc beaucoup de
missions donc vous avez besoin et sur la
disponibilité une demi-journée par
semaine c'est ça peut être suffisant
pour les vaisseaux
bien évidemment nous si vous avez plus
d'une demi-journée on sera ravis mais
une demi-journée c'est toujours ça les
résolutions dans les Yvelines 24 centres
de centres pour pour les bébés c'est ça
pour les bébés et lui aussi des centres
itinérants un centre itinérant dans ces
24 centres en fait cette année nous
avons ouvert deux centres un centre
classique à Magnanville et un centre
itinérant qui est sur les bords de Seine
qui va entre le Port Marly et Lucienne
donc c'est une camionnette qui se
déplace au plus près des personnes
démunies pour leur délivrer de l'aide
alimentaire et des et on leur donne
aussi des cours de français pour ceux
qui en ont besoin des fois il faut se
remettre à niveau sur sur le français
mais nous avons aussi une résidence
sociale à Poissy et deux chantiers
d'insertion et l'objectif sur ces
centres Ikea ce centre itinérant cette
développer un peu plus cet aspect à
l'avenir parce que là vous allez dans
dans des villes comme Marly Marly-le-Roi
ce sont des réflexions qu'on a en cours
de façon dans les Yvelines aussi
nouvelles restos du cœur d'avoir des
centres qui se déplacent donc
aujourd'hui on a par exemple des
réflexions pour aller sur d'autres zones
et aussi d'aller dans les zones rurales
parce qu'on se rend compte que les zones
rurales aujourd'hui ne sont pas
couvertes
Céline est-ce que vous aviez peut-être
une question quelles sont les je sais
pas s'il y en a des conditions pour
pouvoir bénéficier de ces aides alors
pour bénéficier de cette aide en fait il
suffit de frapper à la porte des Restos
du Coeur donc il y a des aides de tout
le monde peut bénéficier c'est ce qui
n'est pas l'aide alimentaire le principe
c'est que toute personne qui passe la
porte qui veut une aide alimentaire elle
a forcément un colis dépannage après il
est vrai que nous avons un certain
nombre de critères quand même
économiques qui ne tiennent compte
notamment des charges énergétiques et
tout on garde le reste à vivre de la
famille c'est quand même un critère
indicatif pour nous mais important parce
que malheureusement on peut pas
accueillir tout le monde et ce qu'on vit
c'est à aider les plus démunis des plus
démunis donc on a ces indicateurs vous
fixez aussi sur forcément le prix de
l'énergie c'est aussi quelque chose de
en fait on va regarder le reste avril en
tenant compte de ce que paye la famille
en loyer ce que fait la famille en
chauffage et puis on va tenir compte de
la taille de la famille évidemment c'est
pas le même critère si c'est une famille
seule ou avec ces personnes merci
Fabienne Lambert d'être venu en plateau
je rappeller responsable des Restos du
cœur dans les Yvelines avec le lancement
aujourd'hui de 38e campagne d'hiver pour
faire un don au resto du coeur pour
aussi prendre contact avec l'association
si vous souhaitez devenir bénévole
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur le lien
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran et dans
l'actualité également la semaine
européenne pour la réduction des déchets
c'est jusqu'à dimanche on vous en parle
de ce sujet tous les soirs dans le 7 8
focus aujourd'hui sur la société yprema
l'entreprise installée à Trappes et
spécialisée dans le recyclage de déchets
du BTP le site vient de fêter ses 30 ans
le reportage de Julien Leroy
la petite ville comment
[Musique]
depuis 1992 de l'autre côté de la
nationale 10 le site
iprima de trappes et spécialisé dans le
recyclage des déconstructions du BTP
béton couche de chaussée ou encore terre
sont importés de différents chantiers
dans un rayon de 20 km en moyenne
alors quand le camion arrive on
réceptionne à la bascule donc là on va
effectuer un contrôle visuel et olfactif
on va prendre tous les renseignements
pour faire ce bon de pesée c'est un
métier qui est primordial sur ce nous
qui dispatchons derrière les camions et
ça permet à derrière de bien répartir et
de pas mélanger l'État en fonction des
différents produits qu'on peut faire
après validation le camion peut
décharger sa cargaison un opérateur
effectue un dernier contrôle visuel pour
éviter la présence de corps étrangers
dans la livraison alors là on reçoit les
matériaux bruts là on est sur la partie
déconstructions béton et on va donc les
recycler et on va les transformer en
produits les blocs de béton sont
concassés à travers cette machine pour
une transformation en nouveau matériau
routier appelé grave béton ils seront
réutilisés pour construire les
fondations des futurs routes les
premiers clients des prémates ce sont
les gens qui font de ce qu'on appelle du
réseau l'eau l'assainissement les PTT le
gaz d'accord ces gens-là ouvrent des
tranchées donc à déposer chez nous sur
les plateformes et prima les matériaux
extraits de leur tranchées et ils
repartent à charge avec des matériaux
pour remplir leurs tranchées donc on est
sur 50 ans en Yvelines et c'est une
ville qui se reconstruit sur elle-même
tous les 20 ans en moyenne donc on a le
besoin d'être là et c'est une chance
aussi pour la casquette les 6 salariés
du site iproma de Trappes reçoivent une
cinquantaine de Cali par jour 70% de ses
véhicules repartent avec de nouveaux
matériaux pour leur chantier
de la rédaction de TV 78 nous a rejoint
en plateau bonsoir Gabriel bonsoir
Céline avec Céline Charles justement qui
est en face de vous et goûter au
meilleur pain au chocolat de France et
il est Yves Linois et oui on va parler
pâtisserie Grégory et le et savoir-faire
français mais surtout savoir faire
yvelinois parce que le 29 octobre
dernier Didier le 2 mai a remporté le
prix du meilleur pain au chocolat de
France donc nous sommes allés à la
rencontre du pâtissier dans sa
boulangerie à Poissy bonjour 3 pains au
chocolat avec ceci dès l'ouverture ils
sont sur toutes les lèvres
traditionnelles ou plus travaillées les
pains au chocolat s'arrachent dans cette
boulangerie de Poissy et pour cause il
s'agit du meilleur pain au chocolat de
France le chef pâtissier Didier le 2 mai
a accepté de nous ouvrir les portes de
sa cuisine là on va découper les pains
au chocolat
avec ce qui s'appelle une bicyclette
ça permet d'aller plus vite
on va
pousser
dans l'autre sens
voilà ça soit bien régulier c'est très
important de la précision et de la
qualité dans chaque étape c'est
essentiel pour réussir un bon pain au
chocolat pour Didier le 2 mai ça passe
aussi par le choix des matières
premières comme ce chocolat venu
dardricourt dans les Yvelines moi je
pense que en France il y a beaucoup de
savoir-faire on a des
artisans on a tout ce qu'il faut en
France c'est ça d'aller chercher ça
ailleurs parce que la preuve c'est qu'on
arrive à faire des de l'excellence donc
si on n'avait pas des matières premières
de qualité on y arriverait pas des
produits de qualité et du savoir-faire
acquis grâce à 35 ans de métier mais la
vraie clé du succès est avant tout dans
la passion et l'amour du partage il faut
aussi avoir l'amour des gens pour parce
que faut aimer faire plaisir c'est tout
ça qui fait que vous arrivez à
l'excellence tous ces ingrédients ont
fait de la viennoiserie chocolat de
Didier le 2 mai la meilleure de France
successifs de pas de beurre pâte beurre
qui comme ça a été bien travaillé
vous avez un bon feuilleté donc un bon
croustillant et un beau et un beau
viennois
et vous mangez ça c'est juste magnifique
je m'en lasserai jamais tant mieux car
prochaine objectif pour le chef
pâtissier le concours du meilleur
croissant une chose est sûre il a déjà
remporté le cœur et le palais des picia
Kay
quelques-uns de ses pains au chocolat en
rédaction il faut le dire disons la
vérité ils n'ont pas fait long feu
remercie d'ailleurs Didier le 2 mai
est-ce qu'il était bon ce Pen chocolat
bah écoutez Grégory je suis pas une
experte empathie mais j'ai beaucoup aimé
en ce qui me concerne je crois que
Céline aussi il était très bon c'est
vrai on en a bien profité pendant le
tournage vous avez goûté dès qu'il est
sorti du four parce que nous la goûter
un peu plus tard en rédaction oui dès
qu'il est sorti du four et c'est ce que
nous disait le pâtissier en fait le pain
au chocolat garde sa saveur pendant 5
heures donc après c'est un peu moins bon
mais bon chocolat qui est mis à
l'honneur c'est aussi ce boulanger
est-ce qu'il y a un élément de son
parcours que vous souhaitiez mettre en
avant quelque chose qui vous a marqué
quand vous l'avez rencontré il y a
beaucoup d'éléments c'est 35 ans de
métiers ça fait seulement deux ans qu'il
fait des concours alors lui il a
découvert la pâtisserie assez jeune il
s'est passionné pour ça très très vite
donc seulement deux ans qui fait des
concours et en fait il a été poussé par
son patron de la boulangerie au soleil
qu'on voit à l'écran et quelle est la
suite des événements pour lui est-ce que
il y a je sais pas moi un concours du
meilleur pain au chocolat au monde et ce
qu'il y a de concours en termes de
pâtisserie de viennoiserie peut-être
alors pour le concours international je
vous avoue que je sais pas en revanche
il nous a parlé du concours du meilleur
croissant c'est l'année prochaine alors
il a déjà participé mais là l'objectif
pour lui c'est d'être premier cette
fois-ci merci Gabriel merci également à
Céline pour se reportage voir rester
dans le domaine de la boulangerie
puisque lui est arrivé en finale d'un
autre concours c'est la meilleure
boulangerie de France l'émission qui est
diffusée sur la chaîne M6 c'est Philippe
laroudé qui vient d'ouvrir une nouvelle
enseigne à Maisons-Laffitte vous pourrez
y trouver plusieurs créations
pâtissières y trouver aussi quelques
classiques et toutes sortes de pain
biologiques Mathilde Franco et Céline
Charles justement vous font découvrir
cette boulangerie boulangerie
viennoiserie et pâtisserie Philippe
laroudé ancien finaliste de l'émission
la meilleure boulangerie de France et
grand gagnant du concours régional du
pain bio vient d'ouvrir sa propre
enseigne à Maisons-Laffitte Crin-Blanc à
Crin Blanc on va retrouver une
pâtisserie on va dire traditionnelle
déjà avec certaines comment dire
revisite on dit aujourd'hui sur la
pâtisserie mais surtout des produits
aussi un peu oubliés quoi et beaucoup
beaucoup de pain bio biologiques de
farine biologique voilà de blé anciens
aussi qu'on va remettre au goût du jour
en l'honneur de l'historique et castre
de la ville mais aussi parce que
Philippe larroudé est passionné par les
chevaux et pour lancer cette nouvelle
boulangerie il a décidé de collaborer
avec Alicia ancienne candidate du
meilleur pâtissier 2022 j'ai accepté du
coup cette belle et jolie collaboration
à Crin Blanc bah déjà maison Lafitte
c'est magnifique c'est un super beau à
l'endroit c'est un vrai honneur et j'en
suis vraiment très fier ça m'intimide un
peu mais je suis trop contente alors
Alicia j'ai découvert sur la meilleure
pâtisserie et j'ai trouvé ces créations
super sympa innovante et voilà et c'est
un talent amateur qui m'a vraiment
bluffé quoi et vous pourrez retrouver
les créations de la jeune strass
bourgeoise au sein de la boulangerie
notamment sa rose pour l'instant tout ce
mois de vous allez pouvoir découvrir ma
rose que j'ai pu faire et élaborer dans
le meilleur pâtissier sous l'attente du
meilleur pâtissier donc j'en suis très
très fière parce que du coup ça vient de
ma tête et vous allez pouvoir la
retrouver en vitrine chez Crin Blanc
Norbert Tarayre animateur de la
meilleure boulangerie de France était
également présente
ça fait maintenant 5 ans que je connais
Philippe puisqu'il a il est passé dans
l'émission de la mer boulangerie de
France il était à Sartrouville et il a
ouvert plusieurs boulangeries donc un
blanc aujourd'hui et donc je vais
suggéré ça serait quand même génial de
pouvoir donner la chance à une à un
candidat qui est amateur dans une
émission du meilleur pâtissier de
pouvoir y installer dans sa boutique des
pâtisseries revue et corriger bien sûr
avec son appui et son œil professionnel
et donner la chance et l'opportunité à
une amatrice de pouvoir devenir
professionnel
et en décembre vous pourrez retrouver la
bûche de Noël made in Crin Blanc ainsi
que d'autres petites surprises
et on passe à présent dans le 7 8 à
notre page culture et on va parler pour
débuter d'un événement culturel qui mêle
la culture à la solidarité c'est la
cinquième édition de solidange je vous
disais tout à l'heure si tu savais avec
caritative au profit du Téléthon qui se
déroule ce samedi à la Ferme du Manet de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le rendez-vous
est donné de 19h à 1h du matin vous avez
entre aperçu la fiche de cet événement
pour en parler deux invités que j'ai
présenté également début des missions
Daniel de salle de l'air qui est le
pilote de cette soirée président de
l'association skyden c'est également
Ceel tir qui est animateur de la soirée
pourquoi une soirée au profit du
Téléthon comment est venu l'idée d'une
telle soirée et bien le Téléthon c'est
une
œuvre caritative qui nous va très bien
parce que pour ces objectifs avec
lesquels on est parfait d'accord
d'ailleurs les résultats actuels
montrent qu'on a bien fait depuis
plusieurs années de travailler pour ce
Téléthon puisque des avancées notable
sont faites qui donnent
du courage aux parents de l'espoir et
une amélioration qualitative pour pour
les enfants et d'autre part aussi on est
très intéressé par la manière dont il
gère
leur association et les dons qui vont
très très très majoritairement à la
recherche je crois que sur les
meilleures années vous êtes monté
jusqu'à 2500 euros sur une soirée
là on va faire beaucoup plus sûrement je
l'espère c'est l'objectif c'est
l'objectif voilà alors avec vous avec
l'association skyden si aussi une
vingtaine d'associations c'est à dire
que les lois aussi grandit autour de
cette soirée une soirée caritative on
l'a dit oui il y a neuf associations de
danse autour de nous et d'autres
associations qui sont d'autres
partenaires notamment le Lion's Club
pour la première fois la Ferme du Manet
qui est vraiment partenaire cette
fois-ci les autres fois à nous
accueillaient mais là les partenaires ce
qui change quand même beaucoup les
choses c'est pour ça que je pensais
qu'on aurait un bénéfice beaucoup plus
important cette année tu as pas de coup
du coup de location de la salle si je
comprends bien ça c'était déjà le cas
d'accord ça montre c'est le même la
municipalité de Montigny qui est à la
fois partenaire puisque c'est grâce à
elle mais il y a des frais techniques
etc et de là la ferme du manège a fait
un gros effort objectif caritatif c'est
avant tout un événement festif aussi
un événement qui festif qui est basé
autour de la danse et puis cette année
on rajoute aussi de la musique du chant
et
on fait tourner beaucoup de beaucoup de
personnes il y a beaucoup de choses au
programme beaucoup de d'ateliers de la
soirée se déroule avec des sous forme
d'ateliers d'une vingtaine de minutes
toujours 30 minutes 30 minutes cette
fois-ci
où l'on va proposer une découverte de
différents styles de danse d'initiation
auxquelles vous pouvez tous venir la
danse indienne la bachata de la danse du
hip-hop
on peut venir c'est à dire que c'est pas
seulement aux initiés à la danse au
confirmer au danseurs confirmés c'est
pour tout le monde c'est vraiment ouvert
à tout le monde et vraiment tout le
monde accueilli et les plus jeunes et
plus anciens et c'est vraiment une
initiation alors ensuite après sur scène
vous avez aussi des démonstrations de
danse fait par des gens un peu plus
professionnels ou des équipes qui sont
montées à travers les associations et
qu'ils vont qui vont vous présenter des
choses et qui vous proposeront aussi
ensuite de répéter ce qu'ils vous ont
montré auparavant sur la scène à côté de
cela il y a des pistes de danse aussi
vous pouvez être un petit peu c'est un
peu sous forme de dance club et c'est ça
sur le tir le disait il y a différents
types dedans sans plus qui sont mises à
l'honneur les danses pratiquées au sein
des associations mais aussi des danses
du monde
des danses dans des associations de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il y a
Bollywood il y a de la danse africaine
la phobie tu as du hip-hop et bien sûr
il y a plus deux associations qui
présentent du hip-hop l'une ce sera
d'ailleurs des adultes jeune adulte et
moins jeune et l'autre ça sera beaucoup
peu plus des ados donc ça sera un peu
différent assez intéressant de voir tout
ça il y a du country et du square dense
surtout aussi c'est toutes les époques
puisqu'il y a aussi
dans les vases qui proposent des danses
avant 1914 mais on aura vraiment pour
tous les goûts avec des ateliers aussi
des ateliers il y a plus de 17 ateliers
de 30 minutes donc on peut pas assister
à tous il y a 5 plages d'ateliers mais
il y a des choses à 1h du matin mais il
faut choisir il faut choisir et puis
quelques petites surprises voilà et du
coup les bénéfices de cette soirée sont
reversés au Téléthon on peut faire aussi
des dons directement au téléphone on
peut faire des dons sur place aussi
c'est très important de le dire
effectivement pour la première fois on
est organisateur de l'événement donc on
aura une urne Téléthon et vous pourrez
directement faire des dons qui sont des
fiscalisés on le rappelle important si
si vous voulez donner 200 euros c'est
c'est 600 euros enfin vous pouvez donner
600 euros et ça ne vaut le coup de 200
euros par exemple donc on peut diviser
par 10 soucis 60 euros et 20 euros la
question pratique pour terminer on peut
venir directement est-ce qu'il faut
prendre une fausse s'inscrire avant ce
qui est bien c'est de s'inscrire soit
d'aller sur le site de solidence soit
sur l'île de Skydance on y accède
directement et voilà on prend son billet
éloasso ça coûte 10 euros et il y a un
food truck pour la première fois aussi
enfin il y a plein de première fois
comme première fois pour cette cinquième
édition de solidence la soirée
caritative au profit du Téléthon qui
déroule donc ce samedi à la ferme du
manège-montigny-bretonneux 19h à 1h du
matin peut-être un appel à passer au
téléspectateurs venez nombreux oui
on s'amuse bien merci à vous deux d'être
venu en parler en tout cas sur ce
plateau et on poursuit cette page
culture avec cette exposition qui est
visible depuis le 18 octobre au château
de Versailles Louis XV passion d'un roi
métal honneur sera fidèle au château de
Versailles qui a régné pendant près de
50 ans l'exposition est visible jusqu'au
19 février on regarde le sujet de Céline
Charles
[Musique]
qui était vraiment Louis XV un passionné
de sciences et de botanique un roi
discret un homme ou multiple conquête
pour fêter le tri centenaire de son
couronnement le château de Versailles
mais à l'honneur ce roi méconnu arrière
petit-fils du roi soleil
on l'a appelé jusqu'à être appelé le roi
bien-aimé mais à la fin de son règne la
situation n'était plus les mêmes les
dernières années de sa vie ont été
beaucoup plus sombres Madame de
Pompadour l'extraordinaire pendule de
passement les souper au cabinet le roi
et la chasse l'exposition propose une
approche plus intimiste de Louis XV où
l'exercice du pouvoir était passé au
profit de sa personnalité cette
expression est consacrée est divisée en
trois parties principales une partie
consacrée à l'enfance l'éducation
l'entourage familial ou non familial de
Louis XV une deuxième partie plutôt
consacrée aux passions du roi et une
troisième partie plutôt consacrée aux
arts autour de Louis XV la qui est
consacré à la chasse dans cette
exposition
se traduit avec l'accrochage de tableaux
qui ont tous figuré dans les
appartements de Louis XV les tableaux de
la salle à manger choisi de gigantesque
tableau de bachelier représentant la
chasse aux URSS chasse à l'ours 400
œuvres provenant de différents musées
français et étrangers mais également de
collections particulières sont exposées
certaines n'ont jamais été présentées
auparavant on peut également y découvrir
le style rocaille appelé style Louis XV
typique de l'époque comme cette commode
du roi cette commode qui est un meuble
mythique qui est un chef-d'oeuvre de la
rocaille qui a été dessiné par ou
imaginer par deux frères endomanis les
frères slot c'est un meuble qui était
dans une chambre royale et on s'aperçoit
que c'est un meuble avec deux portes
latérales de vantaux latéraux et
manifestement c'est vanto latéraux
servait au barbier à mettre le matériel
nécessaire pour la toilette du roi le
matin le parcours offre également la
possibilité de visiter quelques-uns des
lieux les plus emblématiques du château
l'appartement de la marquise de
Pompadour les appartement du dauphin ou
encore la chambre de madame du Barry
dernière favorite du roi une exposition
à découvrir jusqu'au 19 février 2023
au menu culturel vous avez également un
rendez-vous ce dimanche avec la
cinquième édition du Salon du livre
d'Élancourt organisé par les Amis du
passé d'Élancourt en soutien avec le
soutien de la ville et de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
c'est 10h à 18h du côté de la
Commanderie Bernard Delattre est avec
nous pour parler de cet événement je le
rappelle vous êtes coordinateur et de ce
salon du livre et on commençait tout à
l'heure à parler de ce thème de cette
année littérature et cinéma la
passerelle a été souvent faite entre les
deux univers
dernièrement il y a eu le film sur le La
Comédie humaine avec janelli tout ça où
j'étais figurant dedans
enfin ça se voit mais c'est vrai qu'il y
a beaucoup de thématiques entre
littérature beaucoup de romans ont été
les sources de films mais là avec une
dresse c'est l'inverse qui est président
de donneur puisqu'elle a d'abord fait le
film pas d'amour sans amour en
1993 avec Patrick Chesnais
Gérard Darmon Martin Lamotte et le
Suisse Bideau et donc à partir de ce
film elle a fait le roman après elle est
devenue romancée d'un univers à l'autre
revenir aussi de la littérature au
cinéma de la du cinéma
d'honneur cette année c'était
quelques-uns de ses films pourquoi la
choisir elle bah justement
et on a aussi Pascal petit qui a fait
beaucoup de films à une époque de
Téléfilm et qui vient de sortir son
autobiographie aussi elle sera là aussi
on a Thierry de Carbonnière qui a joué
dans Plus Belle La Vie qui a fait du
cinéma qui réalisateur aussi et voilà on
a pas mal de gens on a aussi
Nelson
monfortifs de sport mais il est il est
très doué et on a aussi clair le LUC
Didier Derouin qui s'occupait longtemps
du cinéma de Rambouillet qui a fermé
malheureusement il s'occupait aussi d'un
cinéma à Gif et je sais plus on est oui
le principe on le voit donc on vient
c'est le même principe que dans les
autres salons du livre on peut
rencontrer les auteurs se faire
dédicacer il y a 3 %, s'il y aura des
conférences avec Evelyne dress avec
Claire Le Luc Didier Rouen sur le la
gestion d'un cinéma de quartier de ville
et la troisième conférence c'est c'est
on aurait dû avoir Jean Sarrus mais
des Charlots s'il a fait plein de films
aussi mais il est malade malheureusement
et il est remplacé
environ
55 ans et c'est un événement qui grandit
en année vous arrivez facilement à
boucler le programme à chaque fois
il y a énormément d'auteurs on a pas de
mal à trouver 50 60 hauteur on pourrait
en avoir 10200 ah ouais c'est c'est
dramatique c'est comme si vous avez un
banquet où il y a 30 places et vous avez
80 personnes qui demandent c'est des
choix drastiques et c'est pas facile on
essaie de faire tourner à chaque fois
les gens ils rouspètent pourquoi lui
pourquoi pas moi c'est c'est possible
c'est pas facile et alors justement donc
c'est dimanche mais il y a
avant-première si on peut dire voilà on
est dans le thème du cinéma donc
l'avant-première c'est c'est peut-être
le terme le mieux choisi la veille a une
soirée autour du cinéma justement avec
Evelyne dress elle va animer deux films
le premier film c'est la tendresse
bordel un film un peu culte avec avec
Bernard Giraudeau elle jouait va avec
Bernard les gens de mon âge se rappelle
de suivre c'était trop marrant quoi
c'est un très drôle avec des scènes
dingue et mine de rien c'était quand
même les débuts du féminisme et de
dénoncer le machisme avec humour c'était
moins violente maintenant mais c'était
dénoncé quand même de façon rigolote et
après le film pas d'amour sans amour à
20h30 le fameux film que Évelyne dress a
réalisé produit et là dedans elle rejoue
une Eva près de 30 ans après elle
attendrait ce bordel elle joue à la 4
partenaires Gérard Darmon Jean-Luc
Bideau Patrick Chesnais et Christian
lamotrice
samedi soir avant le salon du livre qui
est dimanche Gabriel une question
peut-être oui j'en profite vous par du
féminisme je crois que Évelyne Drey
c'est très engagée dans le féminisme
c'est c'est d'actualité finalement de
proposer un film
elle a dénoncé ça regardez rien que la
photo là où elle est avec 4 bonhommes on
voit bien que celle qui choisit quoi
mais dans le film il y a montré la
caméra la photo pour traiter le
spectateur s'en rendre compte dans les
films il y a des trucs très drôles et
des scènes que je peux pas décrire ou la
façon dont elle envoie balader des des
machistes tout ça c'est mais cette façon
drôle mais les mecs ils sont bien des
hantés quand même quoi donc le programme
on l'a compris des rencontres avec les
auteurs des conférences également vous
en avez parlé sur les infos purement
pratique l'entrée est libre bien sûr de
10h à 18h non-stop et donc il y a pas
seulement le livre cinéma il y a aussi
les polars avec les éditions La Joigny
un fort rayon jeunesse avec la librairie
Le Pavé dans la main on a un mois de
Noël donc il y aura plein de je pense
c'est un beau cadeau un livre pour
enfant dédicace par l'auteur et souvent
ils font des dessins il y aura aussi le
[Musique]
et puis on va qui parviendra à sortir la
jeune Agnès des griffes d'Arnolphe Louis
a été diagnostiqué autiste quand il
avait trois ans dans l'émission Vy P
Francis Perrin explique à Patrice
carmous comment son fils s'est préparé
pour jouer cette pièce et la joie qu'il
ressent sur scène je vois partager par
sa famille et par le public regarde un
extrait c'est ça qui est merveilleux
et puis c'est son plaisir c'est
de jouer de d'être en scène cette
énergie alors on se demandait bon
on savait qu'il allait qu'il allait y
arriver on a on a beaucoup travaillé
mais comme avec les autres comédiens
d'ailleurs c'est mais on se disait
est-ce que ça va être être régulier
parce qu'on a on joue
près de 100 présentations
on arrive à 95 représentations et ben il
a soit toujours la même énergie la même
régularité le même professionnel
que d'autres cas et surtout cette joie
d'être en scène et ce plaisir de
partager et avec le public
c'est ça qui c'est ce qui est frappant
d'ailleurs c'est c'est en effet oui pour
lui ça doit être une joie immense
évidemment pour vous pour Gersende et
pour sa sœur Clarisse c'est aussi une
loi immense que vous partagez tous quoi
c'est complètement oui oui c'est c'est
un étonnement de chaque instant
aussi mais en même temps c'est ce qui
fait aussi que notre famille
a une complicité depuis depuis très très
très longtemps et qu'elle se recense en
scène et que les spectateurs sentent
cette joie d'être ensemble aussi et
cette admiration enfin qu'on a envers
lui parce qu'on est tout de même
oui oui on est à la fois fier heureux et
puis surtout très très heureux de le
voir le voir dans cette joie de joie
immense de jouer
émission vypr retrouvé en intégralité
sur TV 78 l'application TV 78 et aussi
sur notre site Internet TV 78.com
[Musique]
un petit tour de table Gabriel que vous
êtes amatrice de bons plats de bonne
cuisine vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure
avec le pain au chocolat je crois que
oui est-ce que vous cuisinez
Bernards
en tout cas c'est un rendez-vous qu'on
propose maintenant chaque mardi à nos
téléspectateurs on retrouve les astuces
de nos chefs yvelinois pour réussir vos
plats chez vous Virginie Legrand vous
propose aujourd'hui une idée pour
l'apéritif c'est du saumon fumé
accompagné de pommes Granny de Grenade
et de la chantilly au curcuma voilà on a
un petit peu faim en entendant tout ça
mais regardez cette petite recette et
cette petite astuce de notre chef
Illinoise
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Virginie Legrand je
suis chef à domicile dans toute
l'Île-de-France et je vais vous
présenter aujourd'hui une recette de
saison assez accessible très simple et
délicieuse
[Musique]
éplucher la pomme
si vous faites ça donc pour un apéritif
par exemple avec des amis faites le
vraiment au dernier moment sinon la
pomme va s'oxyder
on va couper ça en brunoise petit dés
d'un millimètre
[Musique]
donc j'ajoute ça au saumon fumé alors le
saumon fumé c'est mon poissonnier qui
m'a préparé du saumon fumé à la ficelle
donc du coup j'ai pu faire des
alors pour la vinaigrette j'ai mélangé
huile d'olive huile de sésame vinaigre
de framboise
vous mettez ça dans des petits
récipients après si vous voulez le faire
en format entrée vous mettez dans une
assiette avec un emporte-pièce
j'ai préparé
une chantilly au curcuma alors la
chantilly petite astuce si vous voulez
faire une chantilly maison alors que ce
soit salé ou sucré toujours prendre de
la crème liquide entière sinon elle le
foisonne pas c'est à dire qu'elle ne
monte pas et elle double pas
[Musique]
donc là j'ai juste mis crème liquide
curcuma sel poivre
[Musique]
pour le
dressage on rajoute des petits œufs de
truite
voilà et des perles de citron
pour le côté acide
donc cesse de citron vert
on peut mettre une petite touche de
curcuma pour le rappel
et on termine avec des petites touches
d'aneth
alors voilà pour vous j'ai réalisé cette
recette de petites pièces apéritives à
base de saumon fumée grenade pomme
granny une chantilly au curcuma les œufs
de truite vous les trouvez en
supermarché et les perles de citron vous
les trouverez sur Internet pour les
professionnels mais vous pouvez vous
amateurs gourmand vous les procurer bon
appétit
Daniel de solder est-ce que vous avez
peut-être concocté ce plat votre femme
tout à l'heure vous disiez qu'elle
cuisinière
ça vous a donné faim Bernard
a plein de vertus c'est vraiment un bon
élément pour le pour le pour la santé
je pense que c'est intéressant voilà
c'est l'astuce du chef de notre chef
yvelinoise vous la retrouvez bien sûr
toutes les semaines sur tv78 il y aura
aussi d'autres chefs Yvelines ou un qui
vous donneront leurs recettes de cuisine
avant de vous laisser un dernier coup
d'oeil à la météo
et ce mercredi a des conditions peu
ouprou que les mêmes que celles
d'aujourd'hui Jean-Pierre mon latin de
la pluie est attendu sur l'ensemble des
Yvelines comptées 8 degrés le matin
Rambouillet Versailles ou non ce sera 9
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie l'après-midi
des gouttes toujours avec peut-être un
ciel plus clair il fera 11 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et Houdan 10
degrés à Rambouillet et ce mercredi 23
novembre nous fêterons les cléments
voilà c'est la fin de ce 7 8 merci de
votre fidélité retour de main avec une
nouvelle édition on parlera notamment de
ce match des Bleus matchs d'ouverture
vous allez notamment suivre ce soir
Gabriel vous serez aux côtés et
supporter de Bois-d'Arcy
une victoire
mondial il dit un héros national
à la place de Karim Benzema forfait le
mot de la fin est que Daniel de salle de
l'air vous allez regarder le match tout
à l'heure on regardait nos imminent
c'est vrai que cette Coupe du Monde pas
certain non en tout cas il sera question
de ça demain dans notre édition du 7 8
on reviendra sur ce match il est bleu et
on espère une victoire face à
l'Australie allez les bleus et très
belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]